the Pentagon is sending more than 3,000
additional soldiers to the Middle East
to protect against any revenge attacks
from Iran chip Reid spoke with two women
who just saw their husbands sent to that
region he is at Fort Bragg North
Carolina with more on this story
chip good morning to you can you tell us
how military families are handling this
situation well I can tell you that when
the president calls 9-1-1 the phone
rings here at Fort Bragg and for the
soldiers of the 82nd Airborne Division
that means that they have to be ready to
go in 18 hours or less and for the
families that means a lot of stress and
also a lot of pride in what they do for
this country just like that yes your
life went from normal family life to
chaos
Rachel hurdle and her husband sergeant
Alexander hurdle were visiting her
family in Ohio when he got the call to
head to the Middle East the previous two
deployments were all planned and so we
had time to get ready this one was this
one threw us for a loop hurdle was one
of thousands of servicemen and women of
the 82nd Airborne Division that
specializes in parachute assault
operations and in responding to
emergency crisis situations anywhere in
the world you admire him for what he
does I do I cannot imagine leaving my
children and I know that it breaks his
heart
but this is what we decided as a family
we would do that we would be a military
theme it's just sad
I just everything he's gonna miss said
Joel Jared Gauss Keys husband left for
the Middle East on Sunday your heart is
swelling with pride like you're so proud
of them but it's shattering at the same
time it is the most unexplainable
feeling I can't even really describe it
and we're at home getting our support
system together and being ready for him
to be gone hurdle and her husband have
one biological son who was eight and
three foster children my children have
finally bonded with a man that wants to
be their daddy and if he were not to
come home how would I tell that to them
this is what military families go
through all the time
but we often don't say it out loud for
security reasons the soldiers of the
82nd Airborne Division have been told
they cannot take their cell phones and
they cannot tell their families where
they're going and if history is any
guide they could be gone for nine months
or even more Tony ship thank you very
much think about that you can't say
where you're going you don't know how
long you're gonna be gone and you get 18
hours of warning before you leave that
wife said it best when she said she's so
proud but it's so shattering at the same
time you know imagine how frightening
and terrifying that must be for ya this
is such of those two conversations we're
so moving I mean with these families you
know give up this is a great piece from
ship I mean it's pride and concern
intermingled once again there are real
people behind these numbers yes you
always need to be families
you